اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء
الدويري الى ماذا يؤشر ما تقول اوكرانيا
بانه تقدم لقواتها في جبهات وعلى مناطق
ثلاث تحديدا
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه لا يزال من المبكر
جدا الحديث عن انجازات ميدانيه يمكن
تطويرها
كما انه لا يمكن الاخذ بالمقاربه الروسيه
بان هناك اخفاقات وتم صد هذه الجمل نحن
امام نفس المشهد من الروايات
المتقابله والمتضادله الان ما يميز الهجوم
هذه هي المرحله الاولى
واستطيع الجزم ان الهجوم الرئيسي لم يبدا
هذه المرحله التمهيديه التي بناء عليها
يتم الدفع بالهجوم الجديد هذه ميزتها هي
في ثلاثه مناطق متباعده اي بمعنى هو تنفيذ
عمليات هجوميه وان كانت محدوده على جبهه
واسعه من اجل كما قلنا الاستطلاع بالقوه
تحديد نقاط الضعف ثم احداث اختراقات
واعتمادها
كمرتكزات لكن رغم كل ذلك اذا قارنا
با الروسيه على تقريبا اخذنا كمثال منطقه
سوليدار الان الحديث عن البلده التي تقع
الى الغرب من سوليدار في ضواحي سوليدار ثم
السيطره عليها خلال 48 ساعه هذا بالمقابل
كانت تاخذ اسابيع في فتره الهجوم الروسي
للسيطره على مواقع هي بنفس الحجم والاهميه
لكن دعني اقول لا يزال الوقت مبكر انما
بدا يعطي انطباعا ان الهجوم سيكون على
جبهه واسعه وسيعتمد على الاختراقات
العميقه الحديث
اللواء فايز هل هذا يفسر كلام مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني الذي قال ما يحدث الان
هو مجرد بدايه
ما مدى قدره اوكرانيا على تحقيق المزيد من
الانتصارات
يعني الان تم الدفع بجزء يسير من القوه
التي تم اعدادها بناء على
التقديرات الاوكرانيه والتقديرات الغربيه
التقديرات الاوكرانيه والغربيه تحديدا
متباينه من تسعه الى 15 لواء يعني هناك
تقريبا سته الويه فرق في التقديرات اي
بمعنى اخر المعلومات المقدمه هي ليست
معلومات يقينيه وليست معلومات يمكن
اخضاعها لعمليه تحليليه يبنى عليها تصور
للمعركه لكن بصوره عامه القوات التي تم
الزج بها هي يمكن ان تكون بمعدل لوائين من
اصل في الحد الادنى تسعه وفي الحد الاعلى
15 لواء الان مدى النجاحات الاوليه في
المرحله التمهيديه واين تقع بالتالي هي
التي تحدد الاتجاهات الهجوم الرئيسيه لكن
نكون دقيقين في قراءتنا الحديث الان عن
ماريوبل بحر ازوف جسر كرش لا يزال الامر
بعيد جدا وليس بمقدور القوات الاوكرانيه
التي تم حجدها ان تحقق هذه الاهداف يعني
التحذيرات الاوكرانيه تمكن اوكرانيا من
تحقيق انجازات قد تفضي الى مسار سياسي لكن
انت تتمكن من استعاده كل ما فقدته بما
فيها القرم اعتقد امر مبالغ فيه ايضا مما
قاله مستشار وزير الدفاع بان الاسلحه
الغربيه تلعب دورا بما قال انه سيطر
للقوات الاوكرانيه على بعض المناطق في هذا
ما تسميها اوكرانيا الهجوم المضاد ما هي
خيارات روسيا في التعامل مع هذا النوع من
الاسلحه التي يبدو انها تدخل المعارك
للمره الاولى
يعني اذا اخذنا بالجمله بنهايه الجم التي
تحدثت بها انت تقصد الاليات المقاتله
المدرعه سواء او غيرها وهي الدبابات
الغربيه الدبابات الغربيه هذه نستطيع
الحكم عليها عندما تدخل في معارك دبابات
او معارك مواجهه حتى هذه اللحظه لا توجد
معارك دبابات
تصادميه هناك هجوم بالمشاه مدعوم
بالدبابات يقابل اما بالقصف الجوي او
بالقصب الصاروخي وتحديدا اسلحه مقاومه
الدبابات الحديث عن تدبير اربع دبابات
لوبارد امر طبيعي جدا وهذه لكن السؤال كيف
تم تدميرها هل دمرت بالقصف الجوي هل دمرت
من خلال دباباتي 72 ام دمرت من خلال
صواريخ كورنيت لانه هذا الامر له دلالته
عندما نتحدث عن القوات المدرعه او
الدبابات الغربيه مقارنه مع ما تم حجده من
دبابات روسيه
تحديدا تي 72 تي 62 تميل الكفه لصالح
الدبابات الغربيه اما الان السؤال المطروح
اين الاسلحه الروسيه المكافئه دباب التي
ستين تي 80 تي 90 شكرا متى لم نشاهدها
شكرا لك اللواء فايز الدويري في عمان